it's a new week at doggie doo good and
the puppies are back on campus a week is
an eternity in the life of a puppy and
if any dogs haven't been working hard on
their studies it'll show only the best
pups will one day graduate puppy prep
[Music]
last week the trainer's noticed
eight-month-old kya preferred the
company of people to other dogs this
week it's beginning to look like more of
the same
[Music]
after a brief hello to the people
however she begins to play with the
other pups a good sign for her
socialization the biggest change this
week is with the oldest pub the dog
formerly known as Deakin like many of
the dogs here Deakin already has a
family waiting for him to finish
training graduation is never assured but
if he passes he'll be going to his
forever family in only two weeks over
the weekend that family informed doggy
do-good that they want to name their dog
Damian this isn't unusual dogs sometimes
go through several names before getting
their permanent name and for the pups
it's actually not that big of a deal the
trainer's begin transitioning a dog to a
new name by using both for instance when
they want the newly christened Damian to
come trainers will say and when the dog
reacts they praise the dog using its new
name after as little as a few days the
trainers can begin to drop the old name
and just call for Damian
[Music]
after some morning exercise the dogs
leave the paddock for some downstate
drills German Shepherd tank seems
distracted
it appears Karen has a treat
while kaya and Luke are only mildly
interested in the feline tank can barely
contain himself this isn't new during
the coming months tank will need to work
on better suppressing his prey Drive his
future family needs to count on him
staying focused when he encounters other
animals the moment that trainer nisi is
distracted tank makes a move but he
never had a chance
Karen releases the cat but tank is shook
it'll be a while before you can regain
focus losing valuable class time
[Music]
meanwhile most of the younger dogs
appear to be doing well a frisbee may be
tempting but these pups know it's a
trick as for Remy after her tough day at
the beach last week
Remy needs to be on her best behavior
today it's not looking good
trainer Karen fetches the
eight-month-old golden and puts her back
into down stay remi should be growing
out of this behavior by now if she
continues to break like this over the
next few months the trainers will have
some difficult conversations about her
continued enrollment if Remy's in search
of a role model Damian's her guy he too
used to have problems staying still but
now even when he's not laying down he
holds his ground even when Paul claps
for him until he hears the word release
Damian knows to stay Damian knows he did
well he is a family waiting for him and
they're counting on this training to
help them for years to come
one woman who's thankful for that
training is Cali Cali is blind on the
right side and after being struck by
cars she never saw coming
she knew getting a service dog could
save her life doggie do-good took
Callie's needs and trained Belgian
Malinois Canaan to meet them perfectly
maybe you didn't notice but all the pups
in training learned to heel on the left
side of a person Canaan however was
specially trained since a pup to walk on
the right this way he can move in front
of Cali if something is about to hit her
at ten years old Canaan is around the
age of retirement for most service dogs
when it's time for Canaan to hang up the
harness he'll live out the remainder of
his days loved by Cali and her family as
a non-working pet
[Music]
to get dogs like Cain uncomfortable
around traffic the puppies need to take
field trips like the one today to the
bus station
[Music]
not all field trips can be to the beach
no matter what a new location means
another local flavor of grass to sample
and also new challenges they may seem
boring to us but buses are a common
reason puppies flunk out of service dogs
school the loud noises cramped spaces
and sudden movements are all huge
challenges for a puppy if a dog can't
become comfortable around a bus there
aren't many options left for a puppy
other than expulsion while they wait to
work with the trainers around the buses
the pups hold tight near some benches if
a puppy were to break from their
down-stay and run into traffic it could
be fatal because of this risk all of the
dogs are tied up during downs day even
someone as far along their schooling is
Deacon Damian I meant Damian
[Music]
one of the first to take a lap around
the buses is Luke as the bus makes
noises Luke is curious but not
frightened this is a great reaction from
the eight-month golden however being
calm around the buses is only step one
Luke still needs to be able to work even
though it's loud he keeps checking in
with the trainer to make sure he's not
missing any commands he otherwise
wouldn't be able to hear one such
command is alert alert is triggered by
an alarm on the trainers watch and while
it's difficult to make out with all the
commotion
Luke is focused enough to hear it
another of Luke's special abilities is
pressure therapy pressure can help calm
those with anxiety or PTSD attacks since
an episode can happen anywhere even at a
bus station Luke needs to always be
ready to spring into action
great work Luke meanwhile back with the
dogs and down-stay trainer Paul works
with Kaia on her new skill steady it's
only been a week since she was
introduced to the command at the beach
but she's learning fast the dog with the
most experience with steady is Damien
[Music]
today however he's practicing his geddit
command and Karen is not making it easy
a slick flashlight a measuring cup
even an oversized mug all pose
challenges but Damien is persistent his
ability to perform his most complex
actions with all the distractions of the
bus station means he's still on track to
graduate in two weeks
keep it up Damien it's been Ally's
turned by the buses at only six months
old but Nellie is the youngest of the
puppies and the most likely to be
frightened to comfort her
Paul has brought her favorite toy at
first she's able to retrieve it with no
problem
but when the loud bus starts up there's
a noticeable change in the pump
Benelli doesn't finish the retrieval and
begins to move away it doesn't take long
though for the puppy to become used to
the sound of the engine so she gets back
to her drills suddenly a new noise
Benelli drops her toy gets low to the
ground and begins to retreat hard her
only focus is getting away from the bus
Paul recognizes she's scared and
immediately tries to encourage the
chocolate lab with her favorite toy
but Benelli doesn't respond Paul gets
down to the Nellie's level and begins to
pet her
even still her only focus is getting
away from the bus this is a puppy
completely shut down her tail is tucked
and she's lost all focus Paul tries to
bring her back on line by rewarding her
for simple down commands but she
continues to ignore her toy a new toilet
gets Bonelli's tail wagging again but
she's still distressed as Benelli tries
to crawl under Paul it becomes clear the
only way to get Benelli feeling better
will be to remove her from any side of
the bus finally away from the noises of
the buses Benelli is soon back to her
playful self when it's time for her to
go back to down-stay she's exhausted
hopefully this was just a temporary
setback for the lab she can't learn to
face her fear of buses there's no way
she'll pass service-dog school mr. pip
it's your turn the undeniable mr. pip
has had issues with loud noises in the
past so if he experiences any other
sounds Benelli did it could spell
disaster for the Yorkie right away he's
reluctant and a treat from trainer Karin
works only for a moment when she kneels
down to his level however mr. pip
discovers some courage mr. pip this is
not what a good heel looks like
because it shows confidence something
mr. pip has struggled with in the past
the trainer lets him pull ahead
sometimes unlike his bigger classmates
mr. pip poses no threat of pulling his
future owners into a dangerous situation
so go ahead and tug a way to make your
size work for you mr. pip now it's our
favorite wildcards trip by the buses
Remy
[Music]
to everyone's surprise the
eight-month-old golden is doing well
that is until the noise frightens not
just Remmy
but trainer Karen as well at first it
looks like a similar situation to
Benelli Rama's tail is tucked and she
looks around nervously unlike Benelli
however Remmy continues to sniff around
and engage with her trainer even next to
the tire when the bus makes the noise
again remi responds better
she continues to sniff curiously still
her tail remains tucked even when the
bus pulls away as she approaches it
turned off second bus the memory of the
earlier noise has her scared
Remmy will have to overcome this
newfound fear of tires to stay in
service dog school so Karen drops treats
to build the goldens bravery even though
she's still nervous
Remy's bounced back wonderfully unlike
Benelli she's stayed by the buses the
whole time a great sign for the young
pup finally it's kaya Stern Sandi the
owner of doggy Doo good already has a
family in mind for kaya this particular
placement means kaya would be around
lots of loud noises that makes today's
trip crucial for the eight month old
goal if she reacts to the loud noises
like Benelli or Remmy
it could mean months added to her
training months that that family would
have to make do without her right away
it looks like Kai is doing great her
tail is up and when the bus hisses she
merely turns her head
as the bus pulls away Paul congratulate
her on her calm demeanor kya knows she
did a good job and she begins to prance
with excitement
she's gonna make some families so happy
and I'm gonna miss her
[Music]
it's the end of a long loud day at the
bus station but there's still one more
exercise in store very slowly
trainer Paul brings Benelli back to a
powered down bus with no risk of sudden
noise this is the safest time for the
chocolate lab to begin overcoming her
fear Paul gets down in her level and
gives her lots of pets helping the puppy
to feel safe eventually Benelli walks
past the bus with relative ease it's
going to be a long road to bus bravery
for the chocolate lab but with her tail
wagging this close to a tire she's made
a great first step the trainer's knew
the bus station would be a challenging
day but they're proud of the progress
from all the dogs for most of these pups
there are still months of lessons ahead
for Damien however there are only two
weeks until final exams will he become a
cautionary tale for his younger
classmates or does he have what it takes
to graduate
puppy prep
[Music]
you